DREA HUDSON: Hi, everybody.
My name is Drea.
I book all the talent
for Live Under The Dome.
So I want to thank you guys for
always coming, and recommending
some awesome bands.
If you guys ever want to
recommend any bands to me,
my email address is Hudson,
H-U-D-S-O-N, 413@gmail.com.
I'll always get back to you, and
definitely appreciate anybody
that you suggest.
So definitely looking
forward to kicking off
Live Under The Dome 2016.
We'll have some great bands
coming up for you guys.
And next, we have ORCHIDS.
They're actually the first
band from Live Under The Dome
to be asked to come back and
perform at today's Google At.
So I hope you guys
enjoy the performance.
I'm really excited to be here.
And yeah, let's rock out.
NICOLE MARIE DESSINGUE:
Hi, we're ORCHIDS.
We're so excited to be here.
Thanks again to Drea
for bringing us.
Drea operates under
the booking name
"Booger Money," so
put that on your radar
if you like awesome stuff.
We're from here in Boston.
I'm Nikki.
This is Jess.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you guys so
much for coming.
Again, if you're
showing up now, we're
ORCHIDS from here in Boston.
This is our second
time at Google.
We feel so absolutely
privileged to be here again--
Google Dome the first
time, and now I'm
here with Jess, which
is my full band-- Jess
Jacobs from Band Without Hands,
another local band who I love.
Badaba.
And thank you so much, Google,
you guys for being here,
and Drea-- Booger Money--
for bringing us here.
And this track is off of an
EP that we just released.
And it's in the back.
It's free for you guys today.
So grab one on your way out.
It's right in front of
the beautiful gentlemen
in the sound booth there who
are helping us out so much.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you guys so much.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS, "SAY
SOMETHING"]
This is a cover.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you guys so much.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
This is a track we did
over at Converse Rubber
Tracks just a few months ago.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you guys so much.
We've got a couple more.
If you're joining
us, we're ORCHIDS.
Thank you so much to Google
and to Drea, Booger Money,
for having us here.
We're so excited.
This is an awesome program
and awesome for you
guys for supporting the arts.
So please take a CD on
your way out and enjoy.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
We have two more.
And these two are also on the
record that just came out.
It's an EP titled "Mystic," and
it's available here for you.
Got a couple other stuff
if you miss out on the CDs.
I have plenty of those.
You're not going to miss out.
You guys having fun?
You dig this thing they do here?
Yeah, you're lucky.
This is really cool.
Thanks again.
Here's another one.
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you so much.
We have one more.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - ORCHIDS]
Thank you so much.
We've been ORCHIDS.
Thank you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]